yeah hello and welcome to this video
covering Game one of the World Chess
Championship match currently held in New
York between your champion magnus
Carlton from Norway and the Challenger
segi kayaking from Russia yeah yesterday
we had to Game one and garden had two
white pieces um actually think this is a
slight advantage for the title order
because that means he also will have
widened the final game which is always I
think nice to have in case of case your
um yeah have your trailing one point you
have widened up in the final game but
let's start with the first game and
contemplate 1d4 it's very difficult to
predict openings on with Carly place
basically everything and it's kind of
this this kind of moving target is very
difficult to prepare against as you
never know what's going to happen he
tends to play sidelines and this is what
happens here plays the Trump offski yeah
one of the more respectable default
sidelines I think that really the
drop-offs key is a pretty good opening
if you look for something that's a
little bit off the beaten track with
white and something while you don't turn
and a risk much and have the chances of
getting an interesting game this is not
bad at all yeah black has a wide choice
you can go worm-like ecigs is very solid
or very sharp it's like c5 this is for
example what I recommend it in my
blackboard one that I released on chess
table earlier this year based on the
bank or gambit this can get to very
sharp positions where black initiates
complications quite early but this is a
virtue championship match and D Phi this
is probably the most classical response
and no surprise that's played by kayak
in here yeah right now um can play III
or you can take on f6 immediately III
first and after c5000 took on f6 yeah
this is typical of the Trump and to take
care and give black those double pawns
the double points against el there
not then week but it's a structural
imbalance and this makes this kind of
capture often um yeah quite
controversial here Carter took on c5
this is not the only move white can also
play em different things he could go
like c3 or 93 and to put pressure here
but D take c5 is a move that has been
seen in cars games he has played this
only I think three of three years ago in
the town memorial against kramnik back
then kramnik played the move from e6 and
it continued with the 90th three and ce4
so it was a pretty normal position white
has given up the bishop and given black
this slide structural discomfort yeah
Kenya can play tonight c16 this is
obviously related the night will belong
here anyway and a difference here is
that after a potential c4 by white just
a possibility then d 4 is an idea this
is a difference to e6 um this was played
now by cards and now Kuryakin took a
long thing quite surprisingly to play is
six which looks like the most normal
firm ever however in black can consider
different things like I'd say eight or
five those moves I worth checking still
unsurprising that he took so long
because this position I think should
have been part of the preparation I mean
this is all speculation but I think
there was a small small chance of the
trompe being played and they should have
looked at it at some point so 20 minutes
is pretty young surprising at this point
yeah contemplate c4 to attack the center
and looks like a logical choice if white
plays be for him to to cover things at
that point I mean this is actually quite
a risky decision for white um
has some various possibilities one thing
that is always interesting is to include
this move and ask about this pawn it so
I'm not clear if white has to cover it
and move like 92 rook g2 and I g3 will
actually trap this piece so who create
could be just um yeah kind of a
non-threat black however can play simple
stuff a five is good attacking this pawn
wine will cover it and now black can go
for a set up based on the most f5 like
this that's a bishop here develops
castles castles and now something with
f5 is interesting to open up this
diagonal there for example what a black
would take here takes clicks cakes and
five and here black has a very very okay
position he is a pawn down but it's got
two bishops and potentially very strong
center like 94 I black and play you know
common way is to cover the porn but then
it's got a five coming like this for
example it's a sharp position I think
I'm i think i'd rather be black here
maybe but it's not it's not clear at all
so we had this move this is probably the
more conservative choice and played
quickly by Carlton has been probably
part of his prep here yet takes on c4
this is probably most logical in other
cases young white would inflict an IQ p
on black and the structure like this is
really quite weak I mean black has
compensation with this bishops but hmm I
think this is a very risky decision
especially against such a great
technical players Carlton is so taking
is very logical black is also not afraid
of young white taking yet to spoil
castling because there's no attack
coming here why doesn't have any
firepower against the black king black
king can easily go to see 708 so
contemplate this don't trade Queen so
early
Bishop c5 was played and now Knight f3
delaying the recapture a little bit um
he was interesting for kayaking to
consider see 3 yeah dropped the pawn
like this he will lose it anyway lose it
back and now with this white the pawn
structure is a bit worsened however it
is not clear that this is so great
because white gets additional options by
having this not to give form so it has
also his- ISM castles castle and all
night a5 that's an interesting where the
night has a look at this pawn and it
basically means that whenever white
captures there will be a knight trade
and I think black is I'm quite quite
happy with this yeah the knight on c6
wasn't that great and maybe trade it off
makes them yeah equality more easily
achievable right of course you could
have simply taken on seat for more like
this that was a possibility but after
i'm not in the capture and e6 it's not
clear that while it is all too happy
with this yeah it's a bit of a funny in
situation here with the two nights and
then a six but why problem you now has
to go for something like this and I'm
not sure that this is such a great
choice and two bishops is always tough
the tough thing to play against if you
have two nights so he played crooks he
won first in this position and after
Bishop e7 that Bishop was exposed now he
could have taken gap and then much mocha
in a more comfortable situation it still
doesn't lead to that much black can play
a 6 in this position I can simply trade
everything down the move Queen c2 was a
little bit more interesting here by
Carlton Bishop d7 very logical here this
biz Bishop is not developed and can be
traded off white has no choice he has to
trade it and now I'm Queens III was
played after Knight takes e4 which was
maybe the most obvious move Black has
rook c8
utilizing this pin and this leads
nowhere I mean something like that one
can play and then for example black can
trade this centralized and yeah the
likelihood of a draw in this position is
extremely high for example you can
easily imagine something like something
like this clap clap and entry agree draw
the accountant probably does not want
that then that easy kind of draw and he
goes for Quincy three yeah i'm looking
at this looking at this night yeah and
now black has a decision we can play
Queen to d5 or can play pawn to be six
and I am yesterday and did the
commentary for the ICC together with
grand master Rhonin hearts we and we
looked at this position quite closely
and we thought that'd be six would be a
good choice IAM making blacks live
pretty easy after nine c4c eight there's
absolutely nothing for whitey has to now
basically pull the plug on the game with
Queen d2 and we just have told my
quality here something like this is just
very equal like f5 you should have six
nothing's going on in more interesting
as this move attacking they have six
pawn yeah and here black can play King
g7 or a five and in both cases we didn't
quite see if white has enough play here
even if I've as possible why can try to
play for those weekend squares but we
didn't think it is all that dangerous
something like here for example Queen c2
and black can always in case of a night
f5 drop back to evade and nothing bad is
happening so it's questionable if white
can play in this way he's a pawn down I
mean and this is some risk um probably I
don't know probably um it would have
been just leading to something very very
equal afterlight see form
can I can play D&D fire forever and here
um I think why it gets a lil something
at least he took it Knight takes here we
expect the drug f.2d one intermediate
move but it probably leads to the same
thing with all the trades rook c8 yeah
now why doesn't have much choice he has
to play rook FC one yeah we could have
had the same position with the rook here
but again Roxy one would be the only
useful move this trade and drooped the
eighth for the maid threat which was
addressed by g3 so we can you get this
ending and yeah what about this ending
this is just that equal on what's going
on in fact it's not totally equal um
White has a slight edge in this position
it's not much but it's a little
something and this is due to yeah blacks
slightly weakened pawn structure the
bishop is not so great in this position
the position is symmetrical there are no
majority is that are being pushed and
this means that the bishops strength
they cannot really be used all that much
plus the bishop it doesn't get an easy
post or or some some some post on the
board where they text something we'll
see the next couple of moves that are
quite logical there like we get we get
here that the bishop is on f6 on a long
diagonal but it's an empty diagonal it
it takes absolutely nothing and this
probably and means that the bishop is
not doing that much while the white
knight can maneuver and a key position
is here after this move keen d8 and we
both expected and pretty much believe
that to happen now that khasinau will
play the movie form after which black
has to take and then continue in this
position here f4e 45 king up white has a
couple of ideas to improve wear black
basically just sits he can do pretty
much nothing and we both agreed that
this would have been not very
comfortable for black to defend it's
very one-sided
and black has zero chances of of any
activity going on so it's something that
we expect it to happen but carven
surprised us by playing the move f4 and
this didn't at first make any sense to
us but we understood and quite quickly
what it was all about first of all
kayaking operate in with h5 you took
this chance to prevent the move g4 and
after a form we found one reasoning
behind their formals because here black
might think Brooks is seven as a good
idea however this actually isn't that
great because white is the most Knight
to e5 either after capturing or
immediately if we look at this let's say
now you five immediately then the ending
here can be extremely tricky like if we
look at one example this kind of ending
is winning for white probably yeah at
least that was our our conclusion yeah
white can come up here and enter on g5
this will be very very difficult for
black to play if we look at this for
example like f6 canyon form came to have
seven c5 black has black has problems
here at the end you might get invited
matt is faced with an outside pass porn
like for example like this this is not a
force variation by the way i'm just
showing a general idea that like this
this could easily easily happen and here
white white would win the game it's a
quite quite interesting there are ideas
here that are not as not easy to grasp
it first roxy seven would be a promise
take kayaking after a longer think when
route d5 and this is also from a
practical point of view much better
choice if you are not completely sure
about going into the opponent in rather
voided yeah it can be a sec stepping on
a minor
boom and you're losing the game even
though before not much what's going on
this is just a better choice now white
cannot go 95 a try tonight c5
threatening the pawn b6 and night to a
six so what is White's idea if won't
won't get this sorry that was a wrong
arrow why would get this in that would
be quite interested in looking at the a7
pawn but with precise defense kayaking
prevents that Bishop e7 and now night b8
was the route to c6 but a 5 was possible
it's not them the nicest move and put
them on dark squares with the bishop
here but it also gives black the safe
square on c5 this is what what happened
here Bishop went to see 5 blocking the C
file and here we actually come to a
position where yeah what can pretty much
do nothing yeah what cars and tried was
to offer the rook trade but here we
imply in a situation where both sides
cannot make any progress they shuttled a
little bit back and forth and now agreed
to a draw so we had a pretty uneventful
game 1 and this is not very uncommon in
World Championship matches the first
games are often not very exciting
because especially with this shorter
formats now those 12 game matches or if
you are not in the final I mean the
short matches they actually push players
towards being more safety focused
because it's hard to come back from a
loss if you have only a couple of games
available to level the score so they
will usually play it very close to the
vest and we can only hope that this will
loosen up a little bit during the course
of the match and the second game will be
played on saturday 12 I'll be covering
this as well hopefully right after the
game because it will be difficult
me too okay see I keep so actually can
do it on Sunday yeah so I will I will
cover it in a reasonable time you're not
like two days later or something like
that yeah this will be kayaking with
white we can be curious what is going to
open with before berlin wall will see
many many possible opening some that
could happen ok guys thanks for watching
i'll be back tomorrow with them or today
with Game two coverage bye bye